meantime uh route 91 permanent memorial
is in progress the plans are in place
let's go back inside of the studio now
hector mejia has a look at exactly what
that might look like hector good morning
heather that permanent memorial is
planned to go up behind the las vegas
strip right at reno and giles that's the
northeast corner of the concert grounds
we have an update from clark county and
we also talked with survivors about that
future site
many who survived the route 91 harvest
festival massacre consider this ground
sacred we lost people
on that property it's unfortunate this
is what the site looks like four years
after the shooting 58 people died in the
immediate aftermath of the tragic events
that unfolded here shauna bartlett is
one of thousands who escaped alive i
think about those families that
told their loved one have a great time i
can't wait to hear about it when you get
back they never got to hear their
stories mgm resorts donated two acres
for clark county to build a permanent
memorial however there's some
controversy surrounding the rest of the
space i think the entire site should be
just the memorial and a parking lot for
the memorial not a parking lot for
entertainment not a parking lot for
tailgating so i asked mgm resorts the
company said apart from a portion
dedicated for a permanent memorial
long-term use plans have not been
established the county appointed the one
october memorial committee almost a year
ago to figure out what to build there's
only
one
chance at this and we want to make sure
that we don't rush the process thousands
have chimed in on what they'd like to
see here chair tanil pereira says
they're in the phase of taking those
thoughts to the arts world for their
input they really want this memorial to
be healing to remember to honor
and to really also reflect the
community's response bartlett says as
she tries to move forward some questions
about that night will never go away why
why
we'll never know the why
when i asked about the land use mgm
resorts said parts of the lot have been
used as short-term parking for certain
events the company said in a written
statement in part we are grateful for
the opportunity to come together and
move forward in the healing process
establishing an official permanent
memorial to reflect and honor victims is
vital to that process we are honored to
donate a portion of the village site
that's the latest on that and those
efforts heather let's send it back over
to you